and another girl  no more fighting no much I got a purse  canal and again I find my middleman same  episode mr. bunny  some families dress a daughter as a boy  because they don't have any sons bachi  posh can be a sort of good luck charm  for future pregnancies unified via Honam  comes to the Medical Center dr. Suresh  helicanus for incident Allah commander  malva hasta food oh no black padded  mother moonshower intercessor don't  shoot a teriyaki boot bad enormous for  not again - sorry daph laughs gunshot  women in Afghanistan can't go outside  and accompanied a boss helps her mother  by going to the market and running  errands she also goes to school hi mr.  Buies are not begin the service today FS  muscular jihad is that fun son okay  put a pistol with you yuck junk fishing  alley Katta Michael Byrne melon am again  families often keep girls and women at  home behind people Amita Freedom House  adenosine a Kakuna Casilla Bichette fish  [Music]  Oh